we heard from the trump campaign and the
gop now let's hear from the voters
our own raymond arroyo is here with
ohioans from both political camps
trump and biden supporters so to get
their reaction to the debate and the
biggest news items of the day
take it away raymond laura the issue of
covid came up at the very top of this
debate i want our voters before we start
to who do you blame for covet do you
blame the president for the deaths
stemming from kovitz show of hands one
two
two of you do that's it why why because
he didn't take the necessary um
precautions to
make sure the people knew about cove and
how serious it was in our community and
he didn't listen to the scientists
and um he didn't listen to the
scientists he shut down he locked us
down for a number of months so he
listened to somebody right it wasn't
barron and melania he was listening
he knew about this um cover 19
and he didn't um be very public with the
with people in the community
kevin very quickly you wanted to say i
think that's monday morning
quarterbacking this is an
unprecedented pandemic that no one in
the world has dealt with before and for
someone to say that i would have done
something different that would have made
a difference
i don't believe it mark very quickly you
know like most americans
i am worn out on the pandemic
and let's just talk about what americans
are concerned about
jobs a paycheck and having some type of
financial security
and we're in a pandemic we're in ohio
and yet
trump has threatened 63 000
ohioans jobs by wanting to have a
boycott
against goodyear i ask is that
the behavior of a conservative
republican okay
i have to go to an exchange on lockdowns
and i'll give everybody a chance
this was a little tape the candidates
had
vis-a-vis lockdowns watch you haven't
ruled out more shutdowns
well no i i'm not shutting down today
but there are look
they need standards the standard is if
you have a reproduction rate in a
community
that's above a certain level everybody
says slow up
all he does is talk about shutdowns but
forget about him
his democrat governors cuomo in new york
you look at what's going on in
california you look at pennsylvania
north carolina
democrats democrats all they're shut
down
so tight and they're dying
okay here in columbus ohioans do you
want more shutdowns
hands no no not a hand in the room uh
go ahead lauren you wanted to say what i
want to say that we can't have
economic success educational success any
kind of success until we get a handle on
covid and that means
doing whatever it is so that we don't
have
224 000 more people dying
okay alex i will say it's very ironic
coming from the party of science and
experts those who urge us to listen to
those people
who don't cite economists who are
experts or child psychologists
who are experts who cite the disastrous
effects of public masks
on children and the economic effects of
the shutdowns those are experts too
we don't listen to them for some reason
yeah no there's a selectivity in there
so very quickly taylor
we have a mass mandate we have social
distancing guidelines we have all these
things in place right now and yet case
is still going up so when is
the point do we say okay we're doing
what we need to do i want to talk about
the minimum wage they debated
both trump and biden raising the minimum
wage watch
do you think this is the right time to
ask them to raise the minimum wage you
of course support a 15
federal minimum i do because i think one
of the things we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to bail them out
too
we should be bailing them out now those
small businesses
are small businesses by raising the
minimum wage that's not helping
alabama is different than new york new
york is different from vermont
every state is different it should be a
state option
do we need a minimum wage increase to 15
an hour yes we do you think so well yes
because um in my community
mothers are happy to take care of their
families and they need to increase
to help provide for their families in
our community does this help small
business you have a small business step
it does not help small business it
harms us and because the pot is only so
big
and if you want to have more pay for
people
you're going to have less people okay i
have to move on to something that was
central to joe biden's pitch and i want
everybody to react
to this it was the notion of character a
decency plea
to voters watch you know who i am
you know who he is you know his
character you know my character
you know our is for honor and telling
the truth stuff is true
about russia ukraine china other
countries iraq
if this is true then he's a corrupt
politician
okay did the president disrupt joe
biden's
decency pitch with that line of argument
anybody hands david
why well he brought his character into
question with all the news the recent
news of
the corruption the the the allegations
that hunter biden might have colluded
with with these
uh chinese interests go ahead taylor
remember this is the exact same things
that they were accusing trump of for
three years with this russia collusion
narrative so now all of a sudden now
it's with joe biden
it's gone and gone away disappeared paul
it's one of my favorite things and one
of the main reasons why i'm going to
vote for president trump is because
there can be no question as to what he's
going to do and no surprises when
he says something he does it and that's
that he made the point over the course
of the debate
not more no more politics this is this
is business this is uh
running as a real person and i really
appreciate that about him
joe biden cast aspersions on this entire
episode
saying this came from rudy giuliani
watch this
we're in a situation where we have
foreign company
countries trying to interfere in the
outcome of our election his own
own national security adviser told him
that what is happening with his
buddy well i don't know well i will his
buddy
rudy giuliani he's being used as a
russian pawn
he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then what happens
do we think in this room is rudy
giuliani the former mayor of new york a
russian
tool a russian pawn nobody thinks that
you do lauren you really do believe he's
a russian pawn
well he has a lot of business interests
he's over there he's talking to uh
all the ukrainian uh the head of the
head of intelligence services for the
united states government is now saying
the laptop is not a bit of
disinformation from russia
but they're authenticating it the the
fact the media isn't fully covering it
we will cover more of this in our next
segment in a little bit
big question who won this debate were
you surprised by anything you saw
sadie you you said you were surprised
what were you surprised by i was very
surprised that trump was able to
follow the rules seemingly in the very
beginning of it
he got a little loose in the end but in
the beginning he he really composed
himself i was
very very surprised you liked the
civility we saw tonight
i did i really did go ahead mark real
quick
that trump did a better job on this
debate but he was forced to do a better
job on this debate but who won the
debate
i would say it had to be biden okay well
i haven't answered that question yet
but i'm going to do it i actually
answered mark i got to give everybody a
shot
who won this debate show of hands donald
trump
joe biden so two of you thought joe
biden won three of you
thought joe biden won everybody else
sadie you're abstaining
who did you think won this but clearly
somebody won this debate
as far as expectations go yep i guess my
the bar was so low for trump that it
really seemed like he might have won
okay and you're our independent we will
leave it there laura back to you we will
bring our focus group back together and
reconvene it
when you join us in here i toss it back
to you oh that'll be fun
it's like through the secret curtain
over there very very
interesting so most everybody two people
said
uh biden won everyone else said trump
won uh one abstained that was
very interesting and i learned something
watching uh the focus group membership
welcome back to the ingram angle i'm
here with raymond arroyo for our watch
party
favors being handed out later uh here in
columbus ohio so let's get right into it
we played this earlier but it's actually
worth playing again
this is joe biden trying to i think
sidestep a little bit a question about
his family enriching itself in china and
the president's response
it's not about his family and my family
it's about your family
and your family's hurting badly you're
sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding
well we can't get new tires they're bald
because we have to wait another month or
so
that's a technical political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family
around the table everything just a
typical politician
the family around the table that was i
mean what's your reaction
who came across better in that response
trump or biden trump
biden why why
he he hit the nail on the head it's
politics as usual
biden's speech to me looking at the
camera point i mean it doesn't do
anything for me it's around your family
table but
apparently there's a lot of bald tires
out there i just know that everyone has
a ball tired
but mark you said biden um it came off
better in that exchange explain
i think what's happening here is we're
talking about china
and trade and a true republican
would never use tariffs ronald reagan
would
never use tariffs nor george bush
in a trade war tara actually ronald
reagan whom i work did use terrorism and
he was called a protectionist
by the cato institute after he left
office reagan
was the start of free trade discussions
in this country
in terms of trying to have it with
mexico and
asia and other locations okay we have to
move on to another topic
obamacare came up biden made this claim
about obamacare
that we seem to have heard before not
one single person with private insurance
would lose their insurance
under my plan nor did they under
obamacare
now millions of people lost their health
coverage
just the fact under obamacare who
in our focus group trusts biden when it
comes
to health care show of hands two of you
why
why because i think um he can continue
to um make sure
people can uh still people who have
pre-consistent
conditions still remain on their uh
policies for their companies
but lauren they said they said then if
you like your doctor you can keep your
doctor turns out you couldn't
well i could and i actually have been on
obamacare
for five years and it was great um
and i i am not a me person i'm more of
an
us person and it's better for america
that we all have coverage taylor young
voter first time there is the law
disincentivized getting health care in
the first place people are willing to
pay the penalty than they are to get the
actual health insurance in the first
place under the law
paul when you look to pay your health
care premium every month whether it's
subsidized by
a business or not did you know or did
yours go up over the last
four or five years it's uh
it's stayed pretty steady um i haven't
noticed any specific change
oh my god mine's like tripled oh
debbie's a small business owner yeah
we're small business owners
small business went way up we're
thrilled this year we're only at a 2.8
percent increase
the less or the least amount we've had
in the last
probably 10 years now biden and trump
couldn't have been
more different in their approach to
china take a listen
if you were president would you make
china pay and please be specific what
would that look like
what i'd make china do is play by the
international rules
not like he has done he embraces guys
like
the thugs like in north korea and
and and the chinese president and putin
and others
and he pokes his fingers now of all of
our friends all of our allies
they devalued their currency and they
also paid up and you know who got the
money our farmers are great farmers
because they were targeted
you never charge them anything
who has a tougher approach to china
biden or trump
i will say from from a farmer's
perspective
the american farmer stands with trump a
hundred percent we saw what happened
uh when when the relief came from the
the trade wars with china and
uh conventional farmers all the way to
sustainable agriculture
uh and everybody in between uh we saw uh
policy become action and benefit from
the policies of the trump administration
we heard that the farmers were all going
to turn against trump remember that
narrative that was always a pretty
strong narrative but
to use their farms as well during the
process
the small the forest i don't know i
think the small the small farmers have
been
declining in america for about 45 years
what we're seeing in this country right
now as far as i can tell is an authentic
revolt of the elites to use the
expression where elite interests
that seem to want to be friendly with
china are are protecting
the biden family on his son and i think
that we're seeing the coverage for for
buy those elites against americanmuscle
we got a wrap but excellent point to end
on a special thank you to our focus
group thank you all so much
you were great participants raymond